hace exactamente cinco años estaba a
punto de convertir mi mamá por primera
vez
rafael el pequeñito que llevaba en mi
vientre era un niño que haya sido muy
deseado yo por mucho tiempo había
querido ser normal y estaba súper
ansiosa por conocer
en el cuarto mes de embarazo
yo que estaba tan ilusionada el médico
el médico en el cuarto mes en el del
cuarto mes me dijo que mi hijo iban a
ser con síndrome de dawn
me lo dijo con tristeza me lo dijo con
mucho pensar
para muchas personas el diagnóstico de
discapacidad es un diagnóstico que duele
que pesa que no debería de pasar
me dolía saber que hablaban de mi hijo
de mi muy amado hijo
solamente llamándolo por sus
malformaciones por sus defectos por sus
irregularidades para mí mi hijo era
perfecto
nadie me habló de dignidad ni de vida de
la que tenemos todas las personas por el
simple hecho de estar vivas
cuando la gente que estaba cercana a mí
se enteraba de lo que ocurría en mi
embarazo pues la gente me tenía como
lástima le dolía que yo estuviera
pasando por una experiencia tan dolorosa
estaba sumida en un espiral que me hacía
estar cada vez peor peor peor y aunque
siempre me sentía mal un momento después
me sentía peor
no estaba dispuesta a dejarme caer
yo quería que mi hijo fuera visto no
como un pobre discapacitado como la
gente que estaban alrededor me lo decía
pobrecito van a ser va a llegar a sufrir
para pasarla mal pues eso no debería
pasarle a él porque pues qué culpa tiene
me decían
había otras personas a mi lado que me
decían algo completamente diferente me
decían no tú eres afortunada que padre
que tu hijo van a ser así es un angelito
dios te eligió para hacer su madre por
algo que vio en ti super especial
me decían que era afortunada porque me
iban a hacer con el síndrome del amor el
síndrome de la felicidad y mi premio iba
a ser tener siempre a una compañía de
eterna porque además mi hijo por su
condición iba a ser un niño que iba a
ser un niño toda la vida
yo no quería ser mamá ni de un error ni
de un ángel yo lo que quería era ser
mamá de rafael y los ojos que yo usaba
para verlos era lo que quería que todas
las demás personas fueran capaces de
encontrar yo no quería lástima ni
privilegios quería simplemente ser su
mamá
cuando las personas ven únicamente el
síndrome de dawn la etiqueta la que
ponen aquí en la frente y pareciera que
es un estigma que luego cuesta muchísimo
quitar
corrían el riesgo de olvidarse de que mi
hijo era un ser humano como cualquier
otro ser humano perfecto no le sobraba
nada no le faltaba nada él así era
perfecto
cuando hablaban de él por lo tanto a
nivel dolía muchísimo que le llamaran
dawn que lo llamaran por su condición
olvidándose de que él era rafael
siempre siempre siempre quiero que las
personas hablen de mi hijo como persona
no me gustan las etiquetas ni para
rafael ni para nadie
tenemos siempre de recordar que las
personas todas somos siempre primero
personas
así como
esperaba cosas antes de saber de su
condición para su vida un día me di
cuenta que esas que sus sueños y que
esas expectativas que yo tenía para
rafael no debían de cambiar a causa de
su condición
yo quería que rafael mi hijo mi perfecto
hijo tuviera la posibilidad de aprender
y estudiar en espacios inclusivos al
lado de personas tuvieran o no tuvieran
su misma condición yo no acepto ni
aceptaré jamás que él corra a espacios
segregados o espacios excluyentes yo no
quiero que mi hijo crezca ya olvidado de
nosotros del resto que vamos corriendo
bien bien rápido súper deprisa dejando a
los que corren diferente detrás
olvidados ahí yo no quiero eso para
rafael tampoco quiero que cuando corra y
crezca y se vuelva un hombre no tenga la
oportunidad de trabajar como la tenemos
nosotros y que tengamos que aceptar las
dádivas que le dé la sociedad yo quiero
que mi hijo sea un ser humano que pueda
defenderse ante la vida tomando el
control de su propia vida
que nadie le robe su voz
cuando descubrí a esta madre de familia
empoderada en la que poco a poco me fui
convirtiendo
un día
llegué con mi hijito en brazos
pequeñitos a un escritorio donde detrás
de él había una doctora una doctora
especialista en discapacidad
yo estaba feliz de poder encontrar a
alguien que me iba a poder ayudar a
sacar adelante a mi hijo
lo que esta doctora vio fue simplemente
y solamente su discapacidad después de
oírle hablar yo creo que tres minutos
su conclusión fue muy rotunda
marta señora usted no acepta la
condición de su hijo usted no acepta la
discapacidad de rafael
evidentemente me supere no recuerdo que
fue una experiencia bien amarga yo sí
pero como esta doctora cree que yo soy
incapaz de ver a mi hijo como él es
porque me dice eso de que me está
hablando y la doctora me decía con
palabras médicas que mejor algo así como
un resultado de errores y de cosas que
no debían de haberle ocurrido porque
entonces yo no estaba dispuesta a
entender que el mundo de él era un mundo
distinto al que tendría si él no tuviera
discapacidad
para mí la discapacidad no era lo que
las palabras de esta doctora me decían
para mí mi hijo era un ser humano igual
a cualquier otro pero que cuando se
enfrentaba en sus condiciones de acuerdo
a sus características a un mundo que le
negaba accesos derechos y oportunidades
allí surgía y nacía la discapacidad la
discapacidad no era algo con lo que
venía mi hijo el algo que le hacíamos
las personas a él cuando lo respetábamos
lo que pasaba cuando lo respetábamos que
no existe ni ritmos ni formas perfectas
cuando nos damos cuenta que cada uno
tiene derecho a caminar a su propio
ritmo
me dolía mucho saber que si mi hijo no
podía el 9 encontrar apoyos él iba a ser
excluido que si mi hijo no se podía
expresar pues él iba a ser haya
abandonado invisibilizado me molestaba
mucho imaginarme que cuando mi hijo
quisiera expresarse y moverse por el
mundo partiéramos del principio de la
exclusión y la invisibilidad era ahí
donde estaba la discapacidad y yo no
estaba dispuesto a aceptarlo
pasó el tiempo y entonces reconocí pues
que sí que la doctora tenía algo de
razón pero no no la tenía por lo que
ella me lo decían partía de una al
principio pero sus palabras tenían
verdad
yo no acepto y nunca aceptaré la
discapacidad que le hacemos a rafael la
que le hacen ustedes la que le hago yo
la que le hace el mundo yo no estoy
dispuesta a que le robemos nadie nada
me gustaría ahorita
que se imaginarán que en esta sala todos
nos pusiéramos un disfraz
el que quieran la máscara que se les
ocurra
pueden verla
detrás de esa máscara somos todos
iguales
no entre tengamos nuestra mirada a las
formas
miremos
a la dignidad miremos a la persona la
etiqueta lo que tenga no dejen de tener
no importa
cuando rafael tenía como dos años y
meses su papá y yo queríamos llevarlo a
la escuela como cualquier niño entonces
pues hicimos una lista de colegios que
queremos visitar y elegimos ir al
primero no íbamos muy felices a platicar
con el colegio para que nos dijeran que
íbamos a necesitar hacer y cómo
escribirlo y todo esto
y cuando yo le dije a la directora que
mi hijo tenía discapacidad me cerró la
puerta en la nariz y tenía prisa por
sacarme de su colegio y me dijo señora
pues es que aquí no sabemos cómo ayudar
a un niño como el suyo
es fuerte saber que lo único que veían
esas personas era la máscara de mi hijo
desde su prejuicio fueron incapaces de
ver al ser humano que tiene derecho a la
educación como lo tenemos todos
que estaban tratando de señalar en el
camino para que me fuera una escuela
segregada aparte
eso no está bien no está bien para
rafael y no está bien para nadie tenemos
que ser capaces de ver a las personas
desde su dignidad y reconocer en todos
los mismos derechos
cuando yo estaba chiquita
kínder 1º de primaria un día mi papá que
está ahí en una foto con rafael un de mi
papá me dijo algo súper importante que
marcó de una manera muy profunda mi vida
mi papá era una persona que había sido
pues pobre toda su vida que había
estudiado hasta tercer grado de primaria
que había sufrido hambre que había
sufrido desprecio y que había sido
etiquetado siempre como pobre
mi papá le dijo marta acuérdate de lo
que te voy a decir
quiero que nunca te sientas más ni menos
que nadie quiero que siempre mijita
siempre veas a las personas a los ojos
sin sentirte por arriba de nadie sin
sentirte por debajo de nadie tú tienes
dignidad
no dejes que nadie te la quite
yo espero lo mismo para rafael
yo espero que la prenda que no es menos
que nadie
que es como cualquiera de nosotros y
tiene derecho a vivir la vida entre
iguales
él es rafael mañana cumple 5
espero que ustedes
puedan verlo más allá de sus ojos
rasgados más allá de lo fácil lo difícil
que puede ser para él aprender algo
espero que lo vean sin prejuicios sin
máscaras sin disfraces sin etiquetas y
que sean capaces de conectarse con el
corazón con lo que nos hace humanos a
todas las personas
no quiero que lo vean ni como un ángel
ni como un pobre discapacitado
espero que lo puedan ver a él al igual
que a todas las personas como
simplemente humanos muchas gracias